(water splashing)
- That's so (beep) weird!
It's like a little fish tank.
(upbeat techno music)
- I think most guys just like boobs.
They can be big, they can be small,
they can be fake, they can be real.
They're good all around.
- If you're not happy with your breasts
and you need to make them bigger
to like feel more confident then,
I mean, so be it.
- It's gonna be like
really hard mochi, I think.
- We're feeling something
that like goes in someone.
Which is kinda weird.
(upbeat disco music)
- Oh, they're like liquid.
That is not what I pictured at all.
- That's, I mean it's like a waterbed.
- I can't get over that noise.
- Yeah, that noise--
- It's such a turn-off.
- Yeah, you can't sound like a dishwasher
when you're having sex.
- To me this feels significantly heavier
than a regular breast.
But I'm also not normally judging
the weight of regular breasts.
- It's a little bit like hardened mochi.
Filled with water.
- It kinda looks like a,
like a jellyfish.
- If I close my eyes, that
does sorta feel like fat.
- It doesn't feel like a water balloon,
it feels just like pure tissue.
- This one feels nice to touch.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, this feels more like a butt.
- Yeah, I ah, it passes the nestle test.
- This is a balloon four days
after the birthday party.
- It's like the T-1000 in Terminator,
when he's like liquid metal.
- It's not as perky as the other one.
- It's like a pancake.
- I feel like this is heavy.
- That's true, like the
skin's gotta stretch because--
- This is a big addition to your chest.
- Feels like it's be a
really good mouse pad.
Like a rest.
- Like a frisbee.
- Dude, I wanna have a water
balloon fight with these.
Just like whoosh!
- It seems like the morality
of breast implant surgery
is something that like women need
to decide amongst themselves.
- If you wanna do something like that,
just make sure you research
everything about it,
like to make sure that you're gonna
be comfortable with what's gonna happen.
Because that's something that
you're gonna have to live with
for like the rest of your life.
- It's not about how
the world perceives you,
it's about how you perceive yourself.
- There are ways to feel
better about yourself
that don't involve surgery.
- You also shouldn't feel pressured
to have a certain size boob.
Because all boobs are beautiful.
- But if they got like stranded
in a desert or something,
and they needed like a
little water supply just...
- Just pop your titty
and drink it. (laughs)